[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
essere qui in mezzo a voi essendo vi
parlerò di quelle cose strane che stanno
per arrivare in mezzo a noi dei robot
intelligenti del robot autonomi
quando ho cominciato a lavorare in
robotica non molti anni fa negli anni 80
ed è una cosa una ri un'area di ricerche
di nicchia facevamo i progetti di
boutique proprio sponsorizzati dalle
grosse agenzie spaziali internazionali
ma la tecnologia non era ancora adatta
all'uso industriale
poi pian piano la tecnologia è diventata
più serie più solida e più affidabile
ormai sono alcuni anni che parlo con i
miei studenti e gli dico che il robot
stanno arrivando l'anno prossimo saranno
qui e adesso finalmente non sono l'unico
parlare di queste cose ma sono altre che
condividono questa opinione
la chiamano in maniera diversa la
chiamano industria 4.0 ma
fondamentalmente la stessa cosa è il
connubio tra robotica e automazione
intelligenza artificiale informatica per
sviluppare dei nuovi prodotti che
cambieranno in maniera sostanziale il
modo con cui lavoriamo in modo con cui
ci comportiamo in modo con cui
interagiamo anche fra di noi sarà una
rivoluzione una rivoluzione industriale
ma sarà anche una rivoluzione sociale e
come tutte le rivoluzioni provocherà
degli scompigli infatti anche nelle
prime nella prima rivoluzione
industriale nell'ottocento quando su un
introdotto il vapore quando le fabbriche
furono industrializzate ci furono delle
sommosse gli operai andavano a
distruggere queste macchine che
portavano via il lavoro e adesso si
ritroverà in una situazione simile e ci
sono dei buoni motivi per preoccuparsi
il primo motivo è che questi cambiamenti
avvengono molto rapidamente
se guardiamo una linea temporale di
queste rivoluzioni industriali
la prima quella del vapore è accaduta
nell'ottocento poi sono passati quasi
100 anni
con l'arrivo dell'elettricità poi altri
90 anni con l'introduzione dei computer
ma adesso stiamo parlando di 40 anni
stiamo parlando di 30 40 45 anni in
attesa di questi nuovi robot autonomi e
robot intelligenti che si aiuteranno
vedremo a compiere meglio il nostro
lavoro e quindi non abbiamo il tempo
fisico non abbiamo la capacità di
adattarsi ed imparare queste nuove
tecnologie
di addestrare delle persone ad usarle
oppure ha gentilmente aiutarle porta
uscire dal mondo del lavoro e
sostituirle con persone più competenti e
tutto uno scompiglio che sta succedendo
adesso oltretutto la giornale i media si
presentano delle statistiche veramente
preoccupante negli stati uniti forse il
42 per cento dei posti di lavoro
potranno essere persi da queste nuove a
causa di queste nuove tecnologie e in
italia uno studio pubblicato questa
primavera
dallo studio ambrosetti nel convegno che
tengono ogni anno cernobbio parla di una
perdita di circa tre milioni di posti di
lavoro quasi il 15 per cento nei
prossimi 15 anni
però ci sono anche degli aspetti
positivi di questa rivoluzione
industriale vi sappiamo tutti ma ad
esempio dal 2000 e 2010 sono stati
creati 11 milioni di posti di lavoro
proprio a causa del questa
computerizzazione informatizzazione del
mondo del lavoro della nostra società
quindi è una sfida una sfida che
dobbiamo affrontare è come tutte le
sfide cosa dobbiamo fare dobbiamo vedere
dal passato come sono state affrontate
guardiamo non passato troppo lontano voi
abbiamo passato abbastanza recente nel
97 ci fu il primo incontro ad alto
livello tra un giocatore un campione di
scacchi garry kasparov e un un computer
dell'ibm di blu è questo questo incontro
terminò a favore del computer i computer
batte il campino del mondo di scacchi
kasparov invece di ritirarsi a vita
privata accolse la sfida e fondò una
società che chiama advanced cell
e questo in questa società i giocatori
sono accoppiati ad un computer quindi a
provincia ha cominciato a provare questa
sinergia tra il la persona
il giocatore umano e il giocatore
computerizzato
un altro esempio che possiamo
considerare è serissimo sottomano una
tecnologia nuovissima una tecnologia
completamente sicura una secondo tempo
utilizzata da persona estremamente
competente che potesse cambiare il
nostro mondo come ci comporteremmo in
realtà la usiamo tutti i giorni o quasi
gli aerei commerciali sono delle
macchine complicatissime sono dei robot
tutti gli effetti guidate da piloti e
altamente specializzati sicurissimi e
hanno cambiato profondamente il nostro
modo di vivere e di muoversi il turismo
il lavoro i viaggi eppure la società non
ha subito dei grossi svantaggi quindi ci
troviamo davanti a questa sfida questa
scelta
le nuove tecnologie possono essere sono
neutre di di loro natura e possono
essere positive a seconda dei valori che
gli diamo pure negative quindi la
domanda che ci dobbiamo porre creeremo
un robot criminale come poteva essere a
terminator oppure avremo a che fare con
dei robot più piacevole più simpatici
come il cucciolo di robot sviluppato a
genova l'istituto di tecnologia
quindi cerchiamo di affrontare queste
questa dicotomia questa sfida che ci
troviamo con degli esempi che spero vi
illustrino le opzioni che abbiamo
davanti a noi consideriamo di utilizzare
questi nuovi robot autonomi intelligenti
per aiutare il mondo del lavoro
pensiamo degli artigiani ce ne sono
tanti qui nella nostra zona che hanno
delle competenze di altissima qualità
producono degli oggetti estremamente
belli unici al mondo
magari stanno invecchiando magari non
riescono a trovare delle competenze e
delle persone che gli possano dare un
sostituto un aiuto faccio un esempio di
un'azienda di alcune aziende veneziano
che creano quello che si chiamano le
foglie d'oro e foglie d'oro sono questi
piccoli
piccole lamelle di oro che servono per
applicazioni alimentari per la cosmesi
per la duratura dei mobili gli artigiani
cominciano a essere anziane è una
lavorazione completamente manuale non si
trovano dei giovani che li aiutino un
robot intelligenti e cosa potrebbe fare
potrebbe mettersi a fianco di questo
artigiano imparare il lavoro imparare i
metodi e le tecniche di lavoro e
aiutarlo degli ultimi anni della
carriera mantenendo il proprio lavoro ad
avviarsi serenamente verso la pensione
recuperare le competenze dell'artigiano
che sarebbero passate al robot non
verrebbero perse e magari attirare anche
più giovani perché i giovani non
farebbero gli apprendisti in una bottega
dell'artigiano ma magari nello studio
informatico e le stesse competenze che
servono per imparare ad operare quel
robo potrebbero essere poi utilizzate in
un'altra azienda quindi potrebbero in
qualche maniera aiutare un mercato di
lavoro muoversi ma questo forse un
esempio un po lontano dall'esperienza di
tutti parliamo invece degli esempi della
medicina che l'area di cui mi occupo
personalmente come ricerca tutti noi
visitiamo un medico spesso abbiamo
bisogno di interventi chirurgici
intervento chirurgico generalmente si
divide in due grosse famiglie interventi
a cielo aperto in cui il chirurgo apre
il paziente perché riesce a vedere bene
il campo ha dato anatomico e riesce ad
avere la destrezza manuale oppure gli
interventi minimamente invasivi che
vengono eseguite con dei piccoli
strumenti che vengono infilati nel corpo
del paziente e con un po di abilità da
prestigiatore i chirurghi riescono a
eseguire l'intervento
da qualche anno è disponibile da una
decina d'anni è disponibile un robot
chirurgico
questo dell'intuito in surgical soltanto
una casa al mondo che produce questo
robot e questo robot alla casa di stile
caratteristica di a copiare la destrezza
e la percezione di un intervento a cielo
aperto con la
il minimo trauma con le caratteristiche
ed un intervento minimamente invasivo
perché d'opera degli strumenti molto
sottili che però grazie a un polso
robotico riescono a permettere al
chirurgo di avere questa destrezza che
avrebbe senza che a senza dover aprire
il paziente
ovviamente ci sono vantaggi per tutti il
paziente ad un intervento più accurato
minor perdite di sangue e il trauma è
molto piccolo e il chirurgo fa meno
fatica
l'ospedale acquisisce un più paziente
acquisisce un immagine di istituzione di
alta tecnologia
quindi va tutto bene e siete un piccolo
dettaglio che queste macchine sono
estremamente costosa e quindi solo pochi
ospedali se lo possono permettere e
pochi pazienti possono usufruire di
questa tecnologia
quindi come possiamo fare a migliorare
ad esempio riducendo il costo
utilizzando un robot intelligente in un
intervento chirurgico
non c'è solo un chirurgo come quello che
vedete lì seduto alla consolle
principale del sistema ma se in un
secondo chirurgo che siede in fianco al
letto per poter aiutare in operazioni
che non sono particolarmente sofisticati
ma se non essenziali per lo svolgimento
dell'intervento deve in qualche maniera
spostare gli organi deve tamponare il
sangue
azioni che possono essere duplicate
abbastanza facilmente da un robot e
quindi potremmo pensare di sostituire
questo chirurgo secondario con un robot
autonomo
ovviamente non c'è nessuna perdita di
lavoro perché se chiedete un chirurgo
che facciamo un robot che si sostituisce
chiururgo fa salti di gioia per i
totalmente tante altre cose da fare che
mi fate un piacere ma ci sarebbe anche
un altro vantaggio estremamente
importante che avremmo subito un secondo
chirurgo pronto per eseguire gli
interventi in parallelo quindi
raddoppieremo il pool di chirurghi
disponibili per operare sui pazienti un
robot autonomo potrebbe aiutare anche il
chirurgo principale potrebbe svolgere
alcune operazioni semplici come delle
suture come dei tamponamenti che possono
essere fatti dare specializzandi oppure
da studenti e infine
il discorso della consulenza se un
chirurgo nel mezzo di un intervento
avessi bisogno di sentire this
confrontarsi con un collega quel collega
dovrebbe venire sala operatoria
cambiarsi disinfettarsi entrare in sala
operatoria con una grossa perdita di
tempo magari per cinque minuti di
intervento
se avessimo robot e intelligente
il chirurgo potrebbe chirurgo esperto
potrebbe collegarsi dal proprio ufficio
lavorare un attimo su robot e poi
staccarsi dall arabo addirittura
potremmo pensare a casa in cui
interventi particolarmente difficili in
cui il paziente deve andare in un
ospedale remoto oppure il chirurgo
esperto deve venire ad esempio qui a
verona potrebbero essere fatte in
un'altra maniera
potremmo avere l'ospedale di verona che
so che compra il programma che è in
grado di eseguire quell'intervento lo fa
non installa sul robot di verona e robot
autonomi autonomamente riesce eseguire
l'intervento con il controllo solo con
la supervisione remota del chirurgo
esperto quindi scenari molto
interessanti per quello che può essere
la telechirurgia ma la chirurgia non è
solo l'unico punto interessante che può
essere l'unico punto che può essere
migliorato da questi robot autonomi
pensiamo anche alla diagnostica a verona
c'è un istituto molto importante che
l'istituto del pancreas è uno dei due
centri maggiori al mondo per la cura
delle malattie del pancreas e ogni anno
vengono migliaia di persone al in
ospedale a farsi visitare
e questa visita è generalmente
imperniato attorno un esame ecografico e
il radiologo deve farlo delle manovre
abbastanza complicate per poter
esaminare il pancreas e bisogna muovere
gli organi non è una cosa molto facile
ma ora dopo potrebbe imparare queste
procedure e questi robot intelligenti
potrebbero essere nei centri satellite
negli ambulatori sparsi in tutta italia
e in europa che fanno capo al centro di
verona quindi i pazienti potrebbero fare
un primo esame in questi sente satelliti
evitare i viaggi a verona e tornare
senza evitare appunto questi questi
viaggi inutili
l'argomento forse più importante del
dell'uso del robot in autonomi in
medicina è quello della sicurezza
pensate che ogni anno muoiono circa 254
mila persone negli stati uniti dovuti
errori medici in italia muoiono circa
100 persone al mese dovute a errori
medici 100 persone al giorno in realtà
dovute errori medici e del 30 per cento
di queste queste queste morti succedono
in sala operatoria
se abbiamo un robot intelligenti in sala
operatoria questo robot potrebbe fare da
direttore d'orchestra del sistema perché
questo perché la sicurezza e questa è
una cosa un po non è veramente ove la
sicurezza non dipende dal fatto che
abbiamo a che fare con delle persone
estremamente istruite ben addestrate con
il macchinario che funziona non ho la
sicurezza in un sistema complesso come
la sala operatoria è una proprietà
emergente che nasce dal fatto che se il
flusso corretto di informazioni che
tutti ricevano i dati corretti al
momento corretto che li capiscono nella
maniera giusta e li sanno interpretare
nella maniera giusta
quindi questa proprietà emergente
potrebbe essere generata assicurata da
un robot che fa da coordinatore
dell'informazione si assicura che ognuno
riceva la l'informazione desiderata al
momento opportuno quindi vedete
abbiamo davanti a noi questa possibilità
di un nuovo connubio come era successo
prima con kasparov tra la persona e il
computer adesso abbiamo la possibilità
di questa nuova sinergia tra la persona
e il robot e ognuno ha le sue competenze
le sue abilità le sue sull'intelligenza
insieme si possono fare delle cose
bellissime
però queste macchine per pur così
intelligenti non saranno mai in grado di
decidere cosa fare dovremo essere noi
persone si spera intelligenti che allo
che remo il robot alle opere nelle
funzioni nelle operazioni nelle cose che
si serviranno saranno migliori quindi la
sfida che dobbiamo risolvere
e questo è nella neutralità delle
le tecnologie vi faremo fare delle cose
positive o gli faremo fare delle cose
negative
quindi saremo pronti per affrontare
questa sfida per i prossimi anni grazie
mille
[Applauso]